alright guys so spring is here it's
finally getting warm and what does that
mean
baseball movies and baseball movies are
some of my favorite films if they're
done right had a 42 stack up 42 stars
chadwick boseman as jackie robinson and
Harrison Ford as the manager who decides
he's going to be the first person to try
to get a black man into white baseball
because back in the day that was
extremely offensive to a lot of people
and Harrison Ford's character is sitting
in his office thinking I want to win the
World Series I want to do something
right I want to contribute something to
baseball and when he does decide to do
this and he does meet Jackie Robinson
this film is essentially a tale of
Robinson getting used to this new world
and the world getting used to Robinson
as he proves himself a great baseball
player and also tries to be a better man
and why as I said in my intro I love
baseball movies they have a special
place in my heart you know movies like
the natural with Robert Redford or Field
of Dreams or my personal favorite the
Sandlot you know if my dog was as ugly
as you I'd shave his butt and tell him
to walk backwards the Sandlot and filled
her dreams were movies that I watched
over and over again as a kid and I even
got into making my own baseball film it
was my first feature-length film it was
called phenomenon field and it is truly
amazing Leigh awful but baseball movies
have always had a place in my heart and
I've really enjoyed watching baseball as
well and going to baseball games and
playing baseball but going into this
movie I was weary of something that a
lot of these movies tend to have these
true stories first off a lot of the
factual information is not factual at
all and second off sometimes it can get
really sappy and very melodramatic 42
definitely has elements involved with it
that are sappy all the way to young
children in the stands praying please
get a hit please get a hit and it's
zooming in on the kid and it's just a
little too much and 42 definitely does
have elements like this nevertheless I
did find a lot of elements about 42 that
were very well done namely the acting
and the directing this is a very
good-looking movie the baseball action
in 42 is very impressively filmed and
the movie looks terrific it does and the
scenes that aren't involving baseball
where characters are talking and there's
dialogue are actually very well direct
- the performances are also really good
as well particularly one I'll get to
that in a second chadwick boseman as
jackie robinson does a pretty good job i
think he does better in the last half of
the film than he did in the first half
and i don't know if that's so much the
difficulty of portraying a man who is so
torn as he is having to deal with
constant racial prejudice at almost all
times and also the film depicts him as a
man who has an extreme temper who's
trying very hard to withhold that there
are times when I felt that he could have
been a little more reserved with his
emotions in his performance in the
earlier half of the film but as the film
progressed and his character matured and
he got better at dealing with that side
of him
I really thought his performance
improved greatly and overall I thought
he did a nice job in the movie and my
opinion the best performance in this
film is actually Harrison Ford he has
that trademark Harrison Ford gravelly
voice but he did something differently
with it it was a little bit southern it
was a little bit preacher s you know
because he does talk about the Bible a
lot in the movie and that's one of the
things they used at first character as
one of the reasons why he continuously
is supportive of non segregation he
doesn't want to have anything to do with
that and he constantly is quoting
scriptures and everything and I find
that pretty entertaining to see Harrison
Ford do that because I've never seen him
do a role like this and I won't lie to
you guys I'll be honest there was one
scene in this film where Harrison Ford
did such a good job at portraying a man
who was trying to withhold emotion that
has been deeply scarring him for a long
time I actually teared up a little bit
because he did such a good job with that
role and I believed that despite the
fact that I've seen that man is Indiana
Jones and Han Solo and so many other
great characters I believe that that was
a baseball manager telling this story
that he was afraid to tell and that was
so impressive to me and I really dug his
role in this movie he did an excellent
job no as I said for me the first half
of the film had a few issues largely
because it does come off a little bit
sappy sometimes a little bit too
Hallmark Channel special some of the
writing is a little too on-the-nose but
for the most part I actually did enjoy
this film and it's largely because of
the fun I had watching Jackie Robinson
continuously school all these players
who think they can get the best of him
simply because his skin color is
different I am so angered by racial
prejudice even today I see it constantly
and I do have a soft spot for movies in
which there is some sort of try up over
that the script is written by the
director as well and he wrote the
scripts for LA Confidential and Mystic
River too
fantastic screenplays the guy is a good
writer he's written some bad scripts
before that I won't mention but he is a
good writer and some of the dialogue and
this film is really well handled as I
said a little bit of it gets a little
cheesy sometimes but for the most part I
did enjoy 42 the baseball action was
great and the performances were very
well done so I'm gonna give 42 of B if
you're a fan of baseball films like I am
if you just want to go see a movie that
reminds you that it's getting warmer
outside finally check out 42 there are
some elements to it that will probably
make you roll your eyes and go huh it's
a little too much for me but I'd say
give it a chance specifically for the
performances and the direction alone
thanks a lot for watching guys and as
always if you like this review you can
click right here and get stuck menage